in the process of doing research for a
book on Harlem I immerse myself in
cultural production so novels films
music and the like because I was
interested in the sorts of stories that
were told about Harlem and the ways that
those stories reflected invented and
shaped social experience of the place I
was particularly struck by a 1975 film
Aaron loves angela in this film it's not
a particular well-known film but maybe
some of you have seen it in this film
two teenagers a young Puerto Rican woman
and an african-american man fall in love
and harlem directed by Gordon Parks
junior who made the classic
blaxploitation film Superfly just a few
years earlier race is front and center
in the story though here was portrayed a
bit differently it was cast into a
broader sea of representations and
dialogues about a place the opening
sequence panned over a dilapidated
streets of a number of Harlem
neighborhoods while featuring a
soundtrack of Jose Feliciano singing
allegro aqui viene Allegro you lata here
comes the black man you locked up Dima
tising this as so many Romeo and Juliet
stories of star-crossed lovers is an
apparently uncrossable divide for Aaron
and Angela Puerto Rican pneus and
african-american blackness became the
fields for navigating romantic
difficulty and ethnicity in this film
corresponding to spatial divides of East
and West Harlem so here were these
spatial sightsee spaces east and west
and racial divides the correspondent
also to a split in a school
oh on Harlem too so people work on
West Harlem or East Harlem or black
Harlem or Puerto Rican Harlem but there
was also a story of what it meant to
step across those borders and it is that
story in all its fullness and complexity
by that I mean solidarity as well as
conflict that I have sought to capture
in my larger project as I explained some
of that work I want to speak about
cross-cultural encounter as an important
way to think about what Harlem means
what does this move and tail and what is
at stake in speaking of Harlem as
cross-cultural our questions I want to
pose here and hopefully engage with the
participants of this seminar as I offer
serve a brief reading of a memoir by
parry Thomas entitled down these mean
streets and a short mention of another
Harlem resident I think is important
Yuri Kochiyama these figures and their
cultural and political investments in
Harlem serve as a window onto the
different sorts of exchanges and
projections that have made Harlem what
it is a vital rich place for racial
formation complex community solidarity's
and dialogues as well as disagreements
and diversity but this proposal of
diversity and multiplicity is not the
same one the capitalist gentrification
produces and promotes gender fires
advocates rather disingenuously utilize
the language of multiculturalism
suggesting that having different peoples
moving in makes for a more diverse place
and this is why I suppose I'm a bit wary
of the language of multiculturalism
because I think multiculturalism is
Ashley being utilized by gender fires to
promote a particular vision of
development Harlem is many things to
many people world capital of blackness
quintessential urban ghetto
Oh site of multiple historical or
contemporary diasporas Puerto Rican
Italian Jewish Mexican West Indian
African and most importantly perhaps the
heart of African Americans political
struggles over race in class almost like
no other one city space Harlem is about
difference writ large and small in terms
of both division as well as solidarity
on the one hand ghetto and on the other
body Oh Harlem can't act productively
among the paradigmatic us frameworks of
race ethnicity in class multiplicity
then is built into the symbol and
experience of Harlem and it is
productive to understand that so what a
close look and what I prefer to call the
cross-cultural cross-cultural rather
than multicultural encounters of Harlem
illuminates are the ways that the
complex back and forth between different
peoples similarly disenfranchised by the
state can construct vital urban cultures
meaning of course that Harlem residents
don't need to be told what diversity is
they live it engage with it every day
and the social space of Harlem is billed
through an understanding of diversities
difficulties and diversities promises
and in proposing the model of
cross-cultural encounter I intend not to
take away from the crucial fact that
Harlem is a central symbol of global
blackness in fact what I argue through
the work that I'm doing is that Harlem's
blackness both in terms of cultural
investments and political struggles has
to been constructed by cross-cultural
encounter the intimate coming together
of all sorts of differences and
projections for movements to achieve
political cultural and social freedoms I
think here we can talk about Malcolm X
and what he was able to mobilize in
terms of transnational and cross
cultural connections developing a deeply
rooted claim on the
scores of multiplicity that it's not
about a sort of integration that serves
the middle and upper classes might
enable us to speak of the interest
investments in Harlem for another
response to gentrification the lines the
sign under which the the memoir that I'm
going to speak about briefly operates
down these mean streets is mobility down
these mean streets there's a sort of
continuous sense that the protagonist
and author perry Thomas is walking the
streets and taking in neighborhoods and
taking in experiences and crossing over
and that's something I want to elaborate
on the back of the book and I'm now
wishing that I had signed it for this
class but the back of the book reads 30
years ago parry Thomas made literary
history with his lacerating lyrical
memoir of his coming of age on the
streets of Spanish Harlem so this is the
kind of back cover of the book and it
sort of it's it's what structures the
book is a cultural artifact right so you
expect really the book to be all about
Spanish Harlem and life in Spanish
Harlem particularly because there's a
kind of training in the literary canon
that there are works on Spanish Harlem
and their works on on black Harlem and
they're very very different in terms of
what they can communicate and the sorts
of communities that they describe and
and to a certain extent the the point
I'm making about what what's on the back
of the book participates in this
dichotomy the lines of the regions of
East and West Harlem again seem to be
quite on porous at least until the book
is cracked open but what becomes clear
upon a close reading of the text is a
sort of imaginary of Harlem that's more
broadly rendered that seeks to capture
something broader about the place of
Harlem east west central harlem black
spanish harlem something ashley more
holistic
the totality of the place is made vivid
through cross-cultural dialogues even
when structured by questions of
blackness what is deeply compelling in
terms of reading this text now is how
this 1967 text its interpretation of a
set of historical experiences and
imaginings is so deeply resonant of the
ethnographic present of gentrification
and the stories of the world that
gentrification is mobilized in which
belonging is vexed and at risk parry
Thomas in 1967 takes on the regional and
racial divides of Harlem even in the
present the traversal of Harlem segments
those central west east regions and the
ethnic communities therein is rare many
if not most residents of several
neighborhoods profess a lack of
familiarity with the others even some
community workers and intellectuals
either know very little about
demographic trends that contribute to
Harlem is growing or historic diversity
or have shockingly few forms of contact
with members of groups other than those
they are directly associated with Perry
Thomas's bird view bird's-eye view on
the other hand is i would say
self-consciously cosmopolitan in the
prologue he speaks from and into a vast
geography quote hey world Here I am this
is a bright moon though my streets my
barrio de noche and quote the world the
Thomas speaks of is simultaneously local
and global inside and outside borders
are evident though frequently crossed as
the book sections are titled
respectively Harlem suburbia Harlem
suburbia down south harlem prison and
New York Tim the repetition makes
explicit both Thomas's divided
Geographic experience and compulsions to
go back to her
but the breaks down south and to prison
opened him up to finally collapse Harlem
into a broader imaginary of New York
town Harlem's meaning then is made not
only in its local context but also in
and through its very circulation here
then life in Harlem can illuminate more
Universal dilemmas about what it means
to live in the world Thomas is engaging
with a broader debate about modernity
putting Harlem into the center of those
conversations as other african-american
writers have done in the narrative
Thomas tackles complex questions of
belonging and membership in the
neighborhoods of Harlem he says quote
sometimes you don't fit in like if
you're a Puerto Rican on an Italian
block but tom is perhaps because he
writes before the multicultural script
for diversity has become hegemonic is
able to evoke these sorts of alternating
forms of intimacy and distance in a
tense turf controlling exchange and i
want to quote a little bit at length
here someone called hey you spic I
turned around real slow and found my
face pushing in the finger of an Italian
kid about my age hey you he said what
nationality are you I looked at him and
wondered which nationality to pick and
one of his friends said all rocky he's
black enough to be a nigger ain't that
what you is kid my voice was almost shy
in its anchor I'm Puerto Rican I said I
was born here I looked around for some
friendly faces belonging to grown-up
people but the elders were all busy
yakking away in Italian I couldn't help
thinking how much like Spanish it
sounded that should make us
something like relatives as Thomas looks
around for support in this confrontation
he notes quote I dug three Italian
elders looking at us from across the
street and I felt saved
but that went out the window when they
just smiled and went up went on talking
I couldn't decide whether they had
smiled because this new whatever he was
was going to get his ass kicked or
because they were pleased that their
kids were welcoming and quote the world
that period habits is an intensely
diverse one in a poignant scene in the
welfare office and it's a depression for
some portion of this book young p
Reese's clear disadvantage and a
humiliation of place through a lens
constructed by relatively broad
understandings of race those that cross
region and particular eyes ethnicity he
observes quote most of the people were
Puerto Rican and Negroes a few were
Italians it seemed that every mother had
brought a kid to interpret for her here
african-americans Puerto Ricans and
Italians are all incapable of being
understood in a sense being seen
likewise no group can properly read the
state they need another generation to
translate shared interests are
constructed through class disadvantage
and encompass racial specificities to
create new meanings for difference in as
much as the state racial izes its
subject populations for this moment
there is perhaps a shared racial
category among quarter Eakins
african-americans and Italians for this
moment I think it's very important that
we pay attention to this world that
Perry Thomas represents and ask what
these historical and contemporary
moments of differential but perhaps at
times also shared racialization among
different groups of people might mean
for how we understand Harlem as a place
for other pneus of all kinds a place
whose special meaning lies in its
ability to contain that kind of
diversity and make of it something that
has a broader claim on the popular
imagination a site that many p
Bulls have been forced to go to because
they had nowhere else and which they
began to call home pierre thomas makes
very clear in his book that he is at
home in Harlem not just Spanish Harlem
but Harlem just as Claude McKay's famous
african-american protagonist Jake was in
home to harlem when Perry's in Long
Island at a high school dance periods
asked by a white girl quote are you
Spanish I didn't know I mean you don't
look like what I thought a Spaniard
looks like puri replied I am a standard
from Spain I'm a Puerto Rican from
Harlem she says oh you talk English very
well I told you i was born in Harlem
that's why I ain't got no Spanish accent
the girl then goes on to compare piras
accent2 another african-american boys
accent and it is there that periods able
to comprehend not only what is going on
with his own subjectivity because the
the autobiography memoir is a kind of
search for the self right like like most
autobiographies are and he's really
searching for a racial self in the text
so he so when so when this when this
girl says this his kind of has a sort of
Eureka moment about the cross cultural
processes of life in Harlem he says yeah
I know Jerry I said softly I know
Jerry's colored and I know I got his
accent most of us in Harlem steal from
each other's language or style or stick
of living and clothe parry Thomas in
fact powerfully embodies both
cross-cultural experience and racial
desire his narrative begins with an
assertion of blackness largely because
he is affiliated with the space of
Harlem for Thomas to be a part of harlem
is to be recognized by and recognizable
within that very much desired space to
be black and Thomas recognizes the
blackness within born of a white puerto
rican mother and
black cuban father who both claimed
whiteness he is at pains to make his own
blackness seen within a familial space
and to convince his family of their own
blackness located as they are in a
suburban space that does not offer those
languages for subjectivity see his
family originally lives in in Spanish
Harlem and then moves out to the suburbs
and when they once I moved out to the
suburbs they really become white and so
that's when he starts to have all these
conflicts and keeps going back to harlem
because that's where he feels um you
know his self can be found and it's a
black self that can be found in harlem
moments of intense alienation
particularly a visa fee his father whose
affection he desperately seeks in
Thomas's family's new place of residence
in Long Island are counter pose to
lyrical descriptions of feeling at home
in Harlem and when Thomas feels at home
he moves to occupy the central
production of meaning in Harlem writ
large to refuse to remain on the
periphery in East Harlem so the point I
want to make here and this and this not
in this autobiography on supposedly
about East Harlem the the main portion
of the text is really about him moving
to black Harlem to Central Harlem if
there is a narrative thrust then it is
in Perry Thomas's locating himself by
the end of the book simultaneously in
blackness in Puerto Rican asst and a
state of belonging to Harlem well before
more critical languages of multiplicity
and was ones that we're so familiar with
Puri Thomas in 1967 produced a place and
a sense of race a good deal more complex
than any simple association of delimited
racial content and geography the
placement of this text within canonical
literature's is a key to some of the
broader issues I've been discussing
rather than a memoir about race this has
become an ethnic text
rather than a story about Harlem it is a
lyric on Spanish Harlem and as
minorities aesthetics are discussed in
terms of Latino aesthetics and not black
aesthetics strangely even for this text
which is all about race the ethnic self
is counter pose to the racial self but
reading down these mean streets is I've
tried to do you know very briefly
against that dynamic in which the ethnic
is so different from the racial we might
see race ethnicity and Harlem in more
complicated ways and the point I think
we want to ask is about whether there's
a Harlem aesthetics and kind of what
would that mean right the migrant of
course is an important kind of figure to
enter into the complex of new
understandings of race in place Perry
Thomas's mother's longing for another
place come into contact with her son's
longings for America which ultimately
lays open the complicated desire for
membership that has made Harlem embedded
as a migrant maybe in cross-cultural
dialogues on the nature of multiplicity
again Puerto Ricans and Italians coming
together coming into conflict over
territory he or she may show us
something new Pierre Thomas walks the
city and takes in experiences and
uncovers connections that an urban
planner might not always be able to do
part of that process involves moving
through neighborhoods and those
neighborhoods national articulations
visa vie Italy Puerto Rico or the United
States implicit but undeniable is the
relationship between countries that are
unequal on the world stage in a name
imperialism migration not only from one
country to another creates then a new
interaction of places the navigation of
cultures this is to say does not only
play out between nation states but
countries of experience within what
might seem to be a kind of local or
parochial space such as Harlem here
Spanish and black Harlem
powerfully come together and result in a
more densely constituted and global
space of course the contact implied by
such encounters is always conflictual in
more recent years perio thomas has had
many opportunities to reflect on the
themes of down these mean streets in a
response to a question about puerto
rican identity thomas almost screams to
the interviewer quote i felt both puerto
rican and black you understand and yet
there was a little part of me that was
why too there was a Puerto Rican woman
who was married to a black doctor dr.
barrows and sitting one day in her house
she looked at me and said I bendito
bitty dibala's appear dead oh what a
pity Perry we are losing you she meant
that culturally and it shook me I was
shaking I was ready to become an
American black and yet I knew that I was
not fully accepted by the blacks I sense
that also when I was a member of the
Harlem Writers Guild and quote Thomas's
desire for blackness does not
necessarily or always mean that he is
black precisely because race and racial
ization are complex historical processes
here to migrants II has a number of
implications even though the experience
of migration was one that structured the
development all all of african-american
Puerto Rican Italian and other
communities it did so in very different
ways migration has always been pitted
against native racialization both in
terms of the state's management of
actual populations and political
discourse and also in the combustible T
of immigrants and African Americans
living side by side with one another in
US cities and a certain exceptionalism
is claimed to as the white ethnic
distances himself from a racialized and
class space and this is you know is a
very long complicated history of
Italians in Harlem and sort of this this
move from your particular forms of
racialization to whiteness right
Thomas's parents leaving Harlem did they
go to Long Island
must be read in this respect to
contemporary claims to space in East
Harlem particularly voiced by Puerto
Ricans visa V Mexican residents now
oddly evoke Italian hostility to Puerto
Rican migrants arriving in the 1940s you
talk to people there's an it there's a
kind of them and inter sometimes an
interesting lack of self-consciousness
about ways that these discourses are
really similar cross-cultural moves then
hardly supersede race though they
certainly reimagine it two years before
parry Thomas published his book the
world saw another powerful image of
cross-cultural encounter in an iconic
Life magazine photograph of Malcolm X's
assassination at the Audubon Ballroom
there was a petite asian woman holding
Malcolm's head as he was dying this
woman was Yuri Kochiyama a former
Japanese intern a civil rights activist
and Harlem resident for much of her
adult life if the visual coming together
of blackness and asianess spectacular
eyes the depth of solid aristokrat with
civil rights at this historical moment
it also expressed on a more micro level
the kinds of intimacy's that could take
shape in the space of Harlem and as it
turns out in Eureka chioma's 126 Street
apartment as well the broad circulation
of this image through generations of
certainly less populous asian-american
radical activist formations and
multiracial coalition's against the
intelligence operation state art I to
ideas about the place of Harlem in
political narratives that are at once
conscious of and transcending its
geographical boundaries remembrances of
this moment process through the
photograph of Kochiyama and a dying
Malcolm X often function in the service
of claims to a more cosmopolitan
sensibility beyond die down
politics about race and therefore about
Harlem as well on the back cover of
Kochi Amoz 2004 memoir passing it on is
a photograph of the author in front of a
sign for the 125th street subway station
the framing image of Kochiyama and
Harlem's most famous street is
symptomatic of her self presentation as
someone whose life story is deeply tied
up with the space of Harlem but Harlem
in this narrative does not function in
any simplistic way as a kind of
shorthand for blackness or radicality
instead Harlem is a vehicle for
cross-cultural political encounter that
Kochiyama values from the very early
part of her life Kochiyama describes her
apartment in Harlem as a meeting point
for activists of many a political and
racial stripe who are coming and going
she talks about how the Freedom Riders
as she's quick to put it an interracial
group of activists met at her house and
she is proud of a home visit from
Malcolm X and his subsequent written
correspondence with her Harlem for
Kochiyama is a political space as well
as one of blackness she notes with
pleasure that her children were quote
influenced by the different aspects of
Afro American culture its music its
dances literature and its sports figures
it was the best place to raise Billy
Audi I Chiddy Jimmy and Tommy Harlem was
a university without walls but heart but
importantly Kochiyama sees the cultural
transfers is almost organic and
remarkably easy never do we as readers
feel the marks of other nests you know
that sense of tourism of the exotic or
the unrecognizable or the inscrutable
and she may even air a little bit in the
sense of in the sense of ease you know I
asked her at some point at a public talk
about whether there was anything kind of
uncomfortable about you know being an
Asian woman the streets of Harlem in the
nineteen sixty said no nothing ever you
know I walk the streets and no
I bother me they just said hello and
smiled broadly and you know it's an
interesting kind of she has a deep
investment in this and in this in this
way that she inhabited Harlem neither
does she nor Puri Thomas seek in Harlem
anonymity nor does either of these
subjects attest to the losing of self or
the shedding of history so Yuri
Kochiyama is very conscious of the fact
that she was a Japanese internee you
know and she lived in Harlem and she
sort of brought a range of politics
together in her life and it kind of in
her place in Harlem if Kochiyama has
affiliated with Harlem and its political
politicized struggles of her race it is
a solidarity then that cannot be
decoupled from her experience as a
political internet' the contrast between
on the one hand her mobility being
actually literally constrained by the
state and on the other hand the
possibility of moving and becoming part
of a new place renders Harlem full of
promise offering mobility and thus a
kind of freedom Kochiyama finds itself
there just as Thomas and others before
them have despite being prescribed by
geography and even race Harlem in these
cases as a social symbolic space is
remarkably open to and I'd like to offer
a note of caution in being too romantic
about cross-cultural encounters while
also asking us to be alive to their
possibilities we might think about the
now historic event a former President
Bill Clinton deciding to have his office
on 125th street in harlem and the
debates that ensued about streets
belonging and all sorts of mobility when
clinton arad the new Black Panther Party
said in response Harlem is ours we will
not allow some cracker named Bill
Clinton to set the stage and the pace to
drive black people out of Harlem others
were more positive Cheryl Babson or grin
an immigrant from Brooklyn said quote
he's a part of me now and henri marie
and older residents head clinton's a
regular homeboy it doesn't matter if
he's in from arkansas this is America
there are competing ideas about dwelling
in these coats and various other
opinions about the move to the question
of whether Bill Clinton can become
member citizen or inhabitant of the
space of Harlem some say yes as a racial
ontology is refigure to allow for Bill
Clinton becoming black in these
responses astonishingly while
territorial legitimacy is held to be
constituted by something called
blackness that blackness can be
conferred flexibility of course in the
case of the nationalism of the new Black
Panther Party the limits of subjectivity
and plays definition are more finely
drawn wideness in that rhetoric is a
form of other 'no sand constructs
another vision of territory so that Bill
Clinton is you know sort of a sort of
fast forward a little bit so the
President Bill Clinton is representative
of the sorts of gentrification that are
also being struggled over Clinton
awakens national longings and also a
desire for local belonging he quite
eagerly draws upon a story of blackness
that said against other historical
understandings appears parochial rather
than cosmopolitan and in so doing he
really shrinks social space to
correspond to a highly localized
geography his proclaimed familiarity
with African Americans through us white
Southern experience is the ground in
which his claims to Harlem are embedded
if the route to intimacy seems at the
very least a bit too simplistic it also
foregrounds a reading of place that
cannot begin to approach the complexity
of interaction and symbolic potential
that many might argue make Harlem a sign
for modern life regardless of what we
think about Clinton the encounter the
cross-cultural move cannot be undone as
one news article queried at the time of
Clinton's arrival quote when if ever has
the
most famous person on the most famous
black street in America 125th street in
harlem Martin Luther King Boulevard been
white well perhaps not with the drama of
bill clinton but cross-cultural
encounters have not only always taken
place on harlem streets but have in many
important ways shaped social life there
the challenge that faces all of us who
work on and are invested in the future
of harlem is how to develop a political
map a political language and movement
that describes the multiple claims on
the place and encourages the
participation of many very different
kinds of communities and yes visions of
place most certainly collide when Perry
thomas presses rocky that sort of
italian kid with whom he is having a
turf conflict to see the harlem hospital
and suss the area of harlem as multiple
econ stituted with more cosmopolitan
content he says with a kind of utopian
air quote there's all kinds of people
born here born there colored people
Puerto Ricans like me and even spaghetti
benders like you rocky replies with
words and force that's a dirty lie bash
I felt rocky some fists smack into my
mouth quote you dirty spic
thomas's mean streets avenues for
mobility and navigation all the same
were deeply fought over it is that sense
of dwelling to that faces all those who
seek to move within and through its
borders
you have a few minutes for questions
comments and play
I'm says so one thing about this
university is like a lot of talk about
the kind of global University
multicultural United States so I
wondered I don't know how much you know
about those efforts but you could like
relate the language around Colombia
being a global university to the kind of
cosmopolitan and sometimes people just
talked about overlaps and contradictions
in my suit that's a good question
especially as that global University
seeks to move into sure that's that's a
very very good question ah well assume
that I mean there's so many ways to
break it down i mean i think first we
really have to grapple with what it
means for something to be global and the
various different ways that that term is
utilized I think you're you're actually
touching I I have a sense that you
you're sort of touching on some of them
even in your question which is that you
know one of my global can be understood
is in terms of the Imperial right in
terms of something that is capturing
many kinds of difference right
harnessing many kinds of difference in
making it home right there's a sense of
the global that's that's about the world
right and in that sense of global being
about the world again is something that
we want to we want to break down and
think through more carefully because if
you think about entry into the world
into the world stage it's never about
equality right different countries enter
onto the world stage become a part of
the global on deeply on equal footing
right so so I wonder if to some extent
we want to find a way to
retain a sense of connection and
diversity while also attending to the
fact that there is difference right
difference in power difference in
relationships and you know I think that
in many ways that the jury is out on on
whether global can the term global can
do all of that at once right ah I think
that one of the one of the challenges
and and pleasures of this project is
about developing a kind of sensibility
about cosmopolitanism you know the sort
of sense of you know people many
different sorts of people's interacting
that is really sort of really attends
closely to difference in inequality and
in what I was trying to describe in
terms of these these figures parry
Thomas and Yuri Kochiyama as as you know
as cosmopolitan and invested in
cross-cultural moves is that they were
also deeply attendant to difference in
inequality and they sort of had a they
had a kind of politics around solidarity
around racial solidarity that was part
of what they understood as you know in
Thomas's a sense of the moon though or
in ureh Kochiyama sensible you know all
these international struggles you know
that that that seemed to her to be
talking to one another right you know
the stage and you know then there's a
lot about her that you know I can I can
say more about but um but I don't think
um always that you know the sort of
guess the short answer the question that
those those two ideas of you know kind
of the global and the sort of
cosmopolitan that I'm talking about you
know the sort of relationship between
different forms of other pneus in a
place in all the place and sort of
really responding to the kinds of needs
and desires of many different kinds of
communities
are that are also similarly
disenfranchised are compatible right is
that get at some of it is I think you
had a second part of that question
wonder i guess the power question gets a
what I've been thinking about especially
like thinking about who care who
actually in the positions of power for
articulating each kind of film and what
kind of communication or lack of
communication between that in who has
the power to enact their inverses I
think that's very very true and and I
would add to that I mean who is defining
what is global right I mean I think too
that there is I touch on this a little
bit that there there can be in some of
these responses to political struggles
around gentrification the sense that
people in Harlem don't really understand
you know kind of what it might be to
have a kind of diverse place or to have
you know to have a Harlem be global and
kind of multicultural and what I'm
trying to kind of uncover an extension
with the sorts of moments you know I'm
interested in I'm describing them
reading and kind of writing about is
that there is a sense of kind of
cosmopolitanism built into the place
right that it's not it's not something
that needs to be it's something actually
that a range of people's actually
already understand even as they are
saying you know your vision of what is
global right is not our vision of what
is global I in a kind of you know
argument against particular plans for
gentrification you know to just speak of
one example
sure well I think partly I mean it's
it's a question of emphasis I mean I
think people have used multicultural and
a range of very important and useful
ways and as well as well as you know
using using cross-cultural but but in
terms of some of the effects of
multiculturalism that I see is
problematic they are the ways in which
multiculturalism presumes that the
differences within the kind of larger
rubric are discrete and kind of whole
unto themselves right that you sort of
have these groups of people that are
sort of very kind of clearly defined
again discreetly defined and that that
sort of that there and that there's this
there's a sense that there's there's
almost a kind of homogeneity within
those groupings right it really stresses
I think that it stresses the total
production of difference of of discrete
differences within a larger rubric now
what I see as cross-cultural is the and
there's you know I can kind of say more
about you know who kind of i'm
interested in one of the the theorists
that I I find really useful for thinking
about the cross-cultural is Wilson
Harris who's a literary critic and a
novelist and essayist you know from from
Guyana who's really interested in the
ways that differences come in contact
with one another and in and in effect
then becomes something new so there's
this sense that that there's something
Ashley productive about encounter and
interaction so the emphasis is on the
cross crossing
the kind of the meeting points and sort
of what happens and the reason i see
that is really useful is because it has
this kind of productive edge right
that's something new something political
something cultural can come about when
differences come into contact with one
another and I think it also and then you
know there's more to say about the ways
that key and other theorists and
scholars develop this notion of the
cross-cultural but there is also the
sense that that differences is is not is
not static or stable it's on the move
it's internally inconsistent or
heterogeneous that there's something
about about about the quality of an
identification or of a community or of a
of a group and how how this group
understands itself that is is is a
mobile that the sort of isn't moving
it's it's sort of its it's dynamic and
that's why that's why in terms of
understanding you know this space of
Harlem I found the cross-cultural to be
so helpful for understanding you know
kind of what's happening on the borders
right what's what's happening not just
on the borders of you know spanish
harlem and black harlem but on the
borders between different communities
within black Harlem where the borders
between different committees with in
Spanish Harlem and then you know kind of
when when those could those those sort
of groups come into contact with another
with one another what happens you know
something new sometime emerges something
conflictive emerges sometimes sometimes
something intimate emerges something
solid juristic emerges so it seems to me
that you know that that it's important
to to think about this place of Harlem
as as dynamic and and the the term
cross-cultural the concept of the
cross-cultural has been has been helpful
and kind of you know eliminating some
some of that in ways that that other
terms have a particularly the
multiculturalism but I don't you know I
I also understand that multiculturalism
has been really useful and at various
historical moments has has generated a
whole range of critical discourses that
are meaningful and you know I don't I
don't certainly don't want a caricature
it but I'm sort of looking at this
particular place and and trying to think
of ways to see certain what's happening
on the edges and new ways very abstract
Ursula I still understand myself
sometimes but in terms of multicultural
is that I almost feel like this that's
almost a product of cross-cultural ism
and in a way you know to me mmm I'm
those interactions and what's being
produced out of that and so I'm going to
see to see to hear your perspective on
the use of multiculturalism and why it
may or may not
hmm well hi I mean I'm interested to
know what you think about it too and you
know sort of what you think about the
ways in which it's been productive I
guess one of the UM difficulties i have
with multiculturalism has to do with the
way that it's been used by various
projects of the liberal nation state to
contain difference and also in some
sense to to kind of gloss over
inequality it has i mean i think in in
certain sorts of discourses and then
again you know this is it's both kind of
it is it does get it does get sort of
quite abstracted moments but but i think
in some of the political effects of the
liberal state using multiculturalism
there's a way in which it becomes
celebratory right rather than conducive
to a kind of deeper inquiry into well
you know inequality and power
differentials right and i think that i
think that there has been you know
politically there have been productive
things about multiculturalism in the
sense of you know or sort of that even
the multicultural state if you want to
call it in the ways that political
interests have developed you know on the
basis of you know kind of racial and
ethnic interests and i think that that's
really important to kind of understand i
mean i think that to sort of throw
multiculturalism you know out the window
would be to serve in some ways not
acknowledge that that that's still very
important to have those sort of
interests you know that are based in
these kind of perhaps discrete
differences but i'm not sure that it is
able to really speak to something that I
think we all face today in really
important ways which is internal
differentiation between the one hand
internal differentiation you know
in these groups right and the ways in
which you know contemporary urban
landscapes are becoming more and more
kind of about interaction you know among
all sorts of differences so we're its
words it's becoming it can become quite
difficult to identify you know one
difference sort of over the other and
that's that's why I love that you know
that moment we're pre Thomas you know
screaming to the interviewer if you get
the sense of you know this is a very
difficult thing to have heard which is
I'm Puerto Rican and black can't you
understand and i think that moment is
very much about you know that particular
and it's a particular historical moment
when he's being interviewed about that
not being able to be readily understood
that you can inhabit both of those
identify corey spaces at once right the
last question because i'm particularly
interested in the park they can grab
that thomas anytime
and how at such a young age he was
already aware of his multiple identities
racially and and how he was a willing to
explore them at such a young age and how
the Italian kid also raised in harlem
was unable to to accept those
possibility of a bat and so i was really
interested in like how you might what do
you think living in Harlan how that
impacted identity development among
among those children or among their
parents in such a way that their
influence their children to say that
it's Italian roots nothing but how how
those two boys and if you walk to make
it and it was a very different racial
ideology yeah I just think that's a
great question i mean i think i think it
is many things right and i think the
sort of i think what you're suggesting
is right that the beauty of that kind of
narrative moment is that both
possibilities why are our present right
on the one hand you know the sense of
multiple identifications and you know
powerful impulses to you know to
blackness to puerto rican is to you know
immigrant miss right and an Rockies kind
of sense of you know italian asst and
turf right at the same time and i think
that i think that life and harlem
produces both of those both of those
things right and more right i think that
and it's it's a sort of a longer story i
think of of how people relate to
territory right and enter moments in
which territory does become ethno size
for racial eyes in a particular way and
this correspondence between place and
race is is very very tight and moments
when
and it can be tight but the sort of the
sense of identification Ashley can be a
little bit more open a little bit more
multiple and and I have to say that you
know part of part of what I've been
really interested in in terms of this
larger project of thinking about Harlem
miss cross-cultural is really trying to
to understand you know both the kind of
survey shull relationship to territory
and also opening it up but not opening
it up in a way that you know suggests
well you know anything goes right so
it's a it's a kind of it's a fine line
to to tread I think that's right